[Music]
let's have a little bit of a size
comparison here one of the biggest
questions in many house of the dragons
fans and to that extent a game of
thrones fans is how big are the two
dragons karaxis and cyrax when compared
to drogon
let's do a bit of a technical analysis
here but first check out these two new
channels that we have started one is
about robotics nut bug and the other one
is mind cue space both of the links are
in the description and in the comments
section
let's take drogon from the last season
of game of thrones
well he was the biggest of the three
drogon grew at a very fast rate i mean
like a fast forward into four kind of
deal
in the first and second seasons he was
the size of a house cat
and then by the later seasons we see him
get an overdrive in growth spurt
by the time of the marine fighting pits
he was the size of a small elephant and
when he and daenerys returned to slavers
bay he was gigantic then next when we
saw him in westeros he had maybe double
or even triple in size so what is the
exact size of this beast in the last
seasons
let's take a reference from one
photograph
we know that jon snow is around 173
centimeters or 5 feet 8 inches tall
so when jon snow met khaleesi for the
first time in dragonstone he also met
the dragons with drogon approaching him
so close that he was able to touch the
beast on the snout
we can clearly see that drogon's head
was a bit longer than jon's nose height
so maybe six feet or 180 centimeters
long
therefore with that in mind we can
extrapolate the length of drogon
we get an estimate of around 100 to 120
feet long or 30 to 36 meters
but some sources say that he is as big
as a jumbo jet at 50 meters or 45 meters
in length
around 150
feet long but that's a bit of an
exaggeration so let's stick with the 120
feet or 36 meters long estimate that we
have brought forward and a head size of
6 feet or 180 centimeters
as the show runners have said that there
are three distinct breeds of dragons
anyway when siren cyrax along with renee
targaryen on the side
so about the size of drogon when he was
in the marine fighting pits and
in between that and the return to
slavers bay
now let's take a look at the other one
karaxis this bloodworm was the dragon of
daemon targaryen the younger brother of
king the series the first
this dragon had a very different body
design with it looking more like smoke
than the other dragon's wings flaps on
the legs that resemble the late
raptorian dinosaurs of the past
estimating the size of karaxis will
prove a bit harder than
doing it for cyrax since the yellow
dragon already had a body reference
similar to drogon and the others
now let's take the scene of caraxies
with demon targaryen in the dragon pit
in one of the scenes we can clearly see
karaxi's head alongside daemon who is
around six feet tall
so karaxis would have had a head size of
around the same size or maybe a bit more
than that just slightly and if you don't
believe me then here is drogon with jon
snow superimposed on the same picture of
daemon and caraxies we can clearly see
that drogon has a head which is more or
less the same in size
in a way the trick here is estimating
the length of corraxies since this
bloodworm is almost like a flying
fire-breathing snake
when we took a look at the scene where
daemon left king's landing on top of
karaxis we can see that even though the
dragon was serpentine in shape it was
just slimmer and appears to be longer
due to its snake-like body even though
it would have had the same body length
as drogon himself yes drogon was very
long yet due to his bulky shape and his
very enlarged upper torso and chest he
appears to be shorter than he looks so
karaxis would have also been around 100
to 120 feet long or 30 to 36 meters or
three times the length of cyrax the same
as drogon but slimmer and not as bulky
so i hope you have enjoyed watching this
video do hit that like button for
support and subscribe as well but most
of all smash that bell icon for regular
updates on new videos right there on
this channel till next one take care fam